so to reset we have a delay in the
confirmation of Donald Trump's Supreme
Court pick Brett Kavanaugh Senate
Judiciary Committee was scheduled to
vote on that Thursday in committee and
then move it on to the full Senate we
now have a delay because of a sexual
assault allegation against Brett
Cavanaugh both Kavanaugh and his accuser
are going to participate in a public
hearing next week now in the meantime
and this is where it is getting
extraordinarily interesting six more
witnesses are wanting to speak are ready
to speak about wrongdoing they claim
they have knowledge of on the behalf of
Brett Kavanaugh and they are worried
about the repercussions they might face
they all went to attorney Cyrus Sanai
who says that he sent a letter back in
July not only to the top Republican on
the Senate Judiciary Chuck Grassley but
also to the top Democrat Dianne
Feinstein saying listen multiple
employees of the federal judiciary are
ready to speak to investigators and tell
what they know about Brett Kavanaugh
they received the the law firm and the
other individuals received no response
from chuck Grassley nor from Dianne
Feinstein he made it clear they have a
story to tell but they're afraid of
retaliation and the subject matter
appears to be things that happened
involving Brett Kavanaugh and his mentor
judge Alex Kaczynski Kaczynski
eventually resigned in shame after
sexual harassment allegations and the
question is how much did Brett Kavanaugh
know about what was going on at the time
how much did Kavanaugh willingly look
the other way about what was going on
and what if anything was Cavanaugh's
actual involvement in the sexual
harassment that was going on at the time
itself during confirmation hearings I'll
remind you Cavanaugh claimed that he
simply had no idea that anything Judge
Kozinski was doing at the time was
taking place he was stunned
he was shocked to hear what Kaczynski
actually did the problem with that
narrow
is that what these potentially up to six
individuals are saying is that they can
provide both testimony and potential
email evidence that actually Cavanaugh
did know and was informed about what was
going on with Judge Kozinski which would
of course once again directly contradict
Cavanaugh's testimony under oath yet
another time the shocking part the part
that we need to look into is not that it
was Chuck Grassley
who ignored this letter from an attorney
representing these six individuals but
Democrat Dianne Feinstein also didn't
respond to the letter I don't know why
but I want to know why so what we need
now number one is a subpoena for the
records that allegedly exist emails
between Brett Kavanaugh and others
including Judge Kozinski from that point
in time number two we need to figure out
how to protect these six people from
retaliation and then let's hear from
them as soon as possible because the
time is now and the term withdraw the
withdrawal of Bret Cavanaugh's
nomination is now being mentioned more
and more it's an early stage all we have
right now is a delay in the vote within
the Genet Senate Judiciary and we will
have these hearings next week Trump has
already been asked about well are you
thinking about withdrawing that
nomination he says that's ridiculous
doesn't matter what he says right now
what matters is what ultimately happens
in those confirmation hearings and
whether we ultimately hear from these
six other individuals later in the show
in the voicemail segment I'm going to
deal with the question of let's assume
for a second that Brett Kavanaugh is not
going to be confirmed what happens and
is the end result just as bad that's
coming up a little bit later but in the
meantime what I want to hear from you
about on Twitter at des Pakman and at
David Pakman show
also on instagram at david pakman is do
you think that these sexual assault
allegations and six new witnesses will
actually impact the confirmation process
or is this just going to be a minor
delay that eventually does see Brett
Kavanaugh appointed for life to the
Court of the United States quick break a
lot more coming up on the program today
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink accom slash Pakman if you've not
already heard about blink Asst it's
amazing it's an app for your phone
tablet or web browser and what they do
is they take nonfiction books popular
nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin recent one is a Robert Rice's
new book the common good
also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudo-science
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n